[Música]
aquí comienza el espacio que France 24
le dedica a medio ambiente soy María
Clara calle y les doy la bienvenida
distintos países están en temporada de
lluvias pero unos padecen más que otros
por primera vez Perú nombró un ciclón y
le puso la palabra quechua yaku que
significa agua su inicio fue el 4 de
marzo cuando se empezó a ver lo que los
meteorólogos llaman un sistema de baja
presión inusual con características
tropicales que en otras palabras
significa que no es un ciclón tropical
como los que hay en el Atlántico Norte o
en el Pacífico de México ya que por
ejemplo no se forma con una espiral
cerrada como nos lo explicó Vladimir
Arriaga del Instituto Nacional de
meteorología e hidrología de Ecuador el
segundo país afectado por yaku
básicamente acá en estas latitudes las
latitudes que están próximas a la línea
ecuatorial es muy complicado ver este
tipo de sistemas
sin embargo se tiene algún registro
aproximadamente hace unos cuarenta
cuarenta y cinco años atrás existió una
formación de un sistema de baja presión
muy parecida frente a las costas de Perú
Pero entonces qué pasó para que yaku se
formara y Perú y Ecuador tuvieran un
ciclón la respuesta está en el océano y
en la atmósfera por un lado las
condiciones atmosféricas tienen que ser
favorables para que los vientos circulen
de manera tal que el sistema no se rompa
y esas condiciones las dio la zona de
convergencia intertropical Pues los
vientos cálidos del verano del
hemisferio sur subieron Y se acumularon
en el trópico por otro lado para que
ocurra un ciclón la temperatura
superficial del mar tiene que ser mayor
a 26 grados celsius y frente a Ecuador y
Perú esta temperatura alcanzó hasta los
30 grados según el inam Vladimir nos
explicó Por qué se calentó tanto El
Pacífico oriental
para las costas de Sudamérica es usual
que nosotros tengamos un transporte
vientos fríos provenientes desde la
corriente fría de Humboldt sin embargo
esa corriente de viento se ha visto
debilitada y los vientos en se han
revertido y esto originado que tengamos
un ingreso de masas de agua calientes
por el océano Pacífico también en los
últimos meses ha ido viajando una onda
cálida una fosa cálida que se traslada
desde el Pacífico occidental pasa por el
Pacífico central hasta llegar al
Pacífico Oriental y esto también ha sido
uno de los principales factores que ha
contribuido para tener este importante
calentamiento así como el océano fue
determinante en yaku también ocurrió lo
mismo en África el ciclón Freddy deja
lluvias históricas en el sureste del
continente en mozambique en tan solo
días ha llovido más del doble del
promedio de un mes y en Madagascar la
lluvia de una semana fue tres veces más
de la mensual el ciclón llegó desde las
costas de Australia allí el 6 de febrero
el buró meteorológico lo nombró Freddy
luego atravesó el océano Índico y golpeó
a Madagascar el 21 de febrero tres días
después tocó tierra por primera vez en
mozambique y siguió hacia zimbabue luego
el ciclón se devolvió al mar y allí las
Aguascalientes le dieron un nuevo
combustible como ocurre normalmente con
estos ciclones por eso cuando volvió a
golpear a mozambique el 11 de marzo era
mucho más fuerte y con una categoría de
ciclón tropical y un día siguiente azotó
a malawin como vemos Freddy ha estado
durante más de un mes por eso la
Organización meteorológica Mundial
designó un comité experto para
determinar si es el más duradero de toda
la historia del planeta como nos lo
explicó José Daniel pretelín
se especula que Freddy pueda llegar a
alcanzar o más bien batir un nuevo
récord de duración el récord anterior lo
tenía el ciclón tropical John el huracán
tifón que ocurrió en 1994 el cual duró
31 días prácticamente un mes en el caso
de Freddy esto ya se excedió ya van más
de 31 días incluso más de esta cantidad
que en que Freddy ha estado activo
entonces van a revisar la Organización
meteorológica Mundial va a revisar la
duración desde el inicio que fue el seis
de febrero hasta la actualidad que ya
más bien son remanentes de Freddy sobre
mozambique y sobre la parte sureste de
África cuánto tiempo Realmente duró pero
es muy probable que rompa este récord de
duración y no solamente el recuerdo de
duración también se habla que Freddy
puede romper otros récords a lo largo de
su vida que te comento fue más de 30
días superando el titán
Uno de ellos es la energía ciclónica
acumulada Este término nos habla
básicamente de la intensidad y la
duración de la tormenta o del ciclón
tropical en este caso Freddy al ser un
ciclón muy duradero Y que además
presentó varios periodos de
intensificación llegando a alcanzar
incluso la categoría cinco en la escala
para medir estos ciclones Pues bueno es
muy probable que también rompa un récord
de energías ciclónica acumulada esta
energía de Freddy es tan fuerte que es
igual a la del promedio de toda una
temporada de huracanes en el Atlántico
Norte según la Organización
meteorológica Mundial Y aunque los
huracanes que afectan a Estados Unidos
todavía no comienzan si hay Fuertes
lluvias especialmente en la costa oeste
por donde está pasando un río
atmosférico como se llama al transporte
de humedad que es tan largo y tan
estrecho que se asemeja a un río como
nos lo precisó José Daniel
estos Ríos atmosféricos no son ciclones
tropicales no están asociados a una
circulación Más bien es un transporte
larguísimo como te comentaba de miles de
kilómetros de humedades de una región en
este caso Tropical a unas regiones que
no son necesariamente tropicales que
pueden ser subtropicales o en latitudes
más altas o alejadas del Trópico esto
puede llevar más agua que incluso el río
Mississippi uno de los ríos más largos
del mundo que tiene una extensión de
alrededor de dos mil setecientos
kilómetros y particularmente el río
atmosférico que está golpeando o que
golpeó duramente a California tiene una
extensión que va desde Hawai hasta la
costa de California del centro Norte de
California y puede tener una extensión
de más de cuatro kilómetros
si bien yacu Freddy y el río atmosférico
se producen casi a la vez no tienen
causas en común de esta manera cerramos
nuestro programa Recuerden que lo puede
repetir en France 24.com nos vemos
[Música]